bye Gidget so long now think about oh I  miss her so much I miss her so much what  they talk about and what they do when  we're not home that ball of fluffs got a  screw loose going to be your brother boy  I got a bad situation I'm your friend  and as your friend I got to be honest  with you I don't care about you or your  problems this is my apartment now  and my new oh dude Katie's gonna be so  upset when she sees that he's gonna flip  out it's just one vase is it Duke is it  oh that's a shame he's gonna be gone  soon  oh my gosh what happened to you oh just  ignore what just happened okay I'll find  your friend oh you bet all time a  paralyzed great  feel heroic low weight but I still look  good I look good  discover the secret life of pets  you're a good boy Leonard